so this kind of hairy looking expression
we're just dividing one complex number
written in blue by another complex
number this first complex actually both
of them are written in polar form and we
also see them plotted over here this
first complex number 7 times cosine of 7
pi over 6 plus i times sine of 7 pi over
6 we see that the angle if we're
thinking in polar form is 7 pi over 6 so
if we start from the positive
real axis we're going to go 7 pi over 6.
so we're going to go 7 pi over 6 all the
way to that point right over there and
then from the origin we're going to step
7 out we're 7 away from the origin so 1
2
3
4 5 6 7 to get to that point
that point
right over there and then the second
number the angle is seven pi over four
so that takes us all the way around here
it takes us all the way
actually i should do it smaller since
that has a smaller
a smaller distance
so
let me
so let's say we start over here so we're
going to go all the way over here to
that point right over here and its
distance from the origin is one you can
imagine that there's a
one in front of that and we want to
divide the two and i encourage you to
pause this video and try to do this on
your own and then plot the resulting
number when you divide this blue complex
number by this green one
well as you might have realized if you
somehow just try to divide it straight
up it can get quite hairy and the way to
tackle it is to write it in another form
and what might have jumped out at you is
that exponential form would be much much
simpler and the way that we convert this
to exponential form is to recognize
that this business right over here
is the same thing this comes straight
out of euler's formula this is
e
to the 7 pi
over 6
i
7 pi over 6 i that's this expression
right over here so this entire top
complex number could be rewritten as
7
e
to the 7 pi
over 6
i
and this bottom complex number can be
rewritten as
as
1 times we don't really have to write
the 1 but this bottom part right over
here is going to be the same thing as e
to the 7 pi over 4 i
7 pi
over 4i and this comes straight out of
euler's formula when you write it in
this way then we can just use exponent
properties to simplify it
we have the same base and so we can just
subtract this exponent from that
exponent right over there so this is
going to be equal to well 7 divided by 1
is just 7. so it's going to be 7
to the
or 7 times
e let me just in a brighter color
7 times e
to the
7
pi
over 6 i
minus
minus 7 pi over 4 i
minus 7 pi over 4 i power
so what is this going to be equal to
well if i have 7 pi over 6 of something
and i subtract 7 pi over 4 of that thing
how many do i have left over
well let's see i'm i'm essentially let's
just
rewrite let me just rewrite all of this
this is really just about subtracting
fractions at this point so if i were to
rewrite this let's see if i write it
with a denominator 12 then i'll have a
common denominator it's my least common
multiple of 6 and four so this one i can
rewrite as 14 pi i
over 12. i can write it as 14 pi
like let me just write this 14 pi i
over
12
and then minus so i multiply the
numerator and denominator by 3
minus
21
pi
pi i
pi i
over
12 as well right i just multiply
numerator and denominator by 3 right
over here and so this is going to be
equal to i'm going to have
12 in the denominator 14 pi i minus 21
pi i is going to be negative 7
negative
7
pi
i
so
this thing is equal to
7
e
to the negative
7 pi i
over
over
12.
now let's see if we can do a decent job
of plotting this so let's see each of
these increments that they've done let's
see in each of these quadrants we have
one two three four five six so they
split this quadrant into six equal
angles and this quadrant is pi over two
so each of these are pi over 12 each of
these little
sub angles are pi over 12. so we're
going to have negative 7
pi over 12. so we're going to go in the
negative direction we're going to go
counterclockwise or sorry we're going to
go clockwise so we're going to go let me
start here and so if i go 1
gets us right over
there did i do that right that that
doesn't let me let me make sure i got
that let me show make sure i got that
negative 7.
so each of these are pi over let me make
sure so this whole thing is
pi
so we have one
wait let me make sure this whole thing
is pi we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12. so each of these are 12 of that so
it's pi over 12 that's right and we want
to go negative 7 of them negative 1
negative 2 negative 3 negative 4
negative 5 negative 6 negative 7. oh
yeah i just kept going all the way to
negative 12 the last time so this is the
angle
this is our this is our angle right over
here and our distance that we go out
from the origin is seven so we go out
one
two
three
four
five six
seven so we come out right
over there so this complex number
divided by that complex number is equal
to this complex number 7 times e to the
negative 7 pi i over 12. and if we
wanted to now write this in polar form
we of course could we could say that
this is the same thing as 7
times cosine of negative 7 pi
over 12
plus i sine
of
of
negative seven pi
over
12.